i will never forget this feeling of
running down this hall and
seeing that morph right there i will oh
it's just so good man it's such a subtle
thing too
people of the internet
what's up guys welcome back
to the monday night stream retro
wrecking tour live
we're starting with super mario 64
because
it is the one that started it all dude
the feels man the feels just
just listening to that oh my goodness
you guys
dude the feels right now i don't
remember anything i remember so
little lucky too what's up dude what's
up
two good afternoon the lackey two
brothers here reporting
live from just outside the princess's
castle
trying to decide if i like a or b better
to jump
[Music]
i had to be quiet for that part dude
just iconic man
the music right there look at this the
one mario game where you can just
punch a goomba i mean we kind of tackled
him right there but
we kind of tackled that one a little
dive all right
i feel like i'm playing fall guys all of
a sudden
[Music]
see like still this game is still
influencing games to this day like those
little balls rolling right there
i mean does that not make you think like
fall guys chat
there he is the big boy he's up here
waiting what's up dude
all right he's telling me what to do
remember can you pick me up from the
back and hurl me to this royal turf i
think you could that you cannot
all right let's see let's see
[Music]
oh no there he goes dude there he goes
there he goes
oh he's mad dude he's mad he comes back
[Music]
you must fight with honor it is against
the royal rules to throw the king out of
the ring
no no you punk hey
how come it's not against the rules for
you buddy
[Music]
give him another toss
no no no dude no no no no come on get up
get up get up get up
yes yes yes i was going for that quick
one man
let's go for that quick elimination all
right that's three see there we go
what can it be that a bib squeak like
you has defused the
bomb king yeah give me that star
boy first
star started gaming in college have a
friend who had all the consoles
it's funny i feel like everybody had
that friend you know
everybody had that friend who just like
got them all
and that for some reason that reasoning
never worked with my parents like you
know you know what so and so they
they've got this and this
it was worth it it was that was worth it
right there be able to get two hits on
that
come on
[Music]
yes yes yes chat we got it
i don't even know what just happened did
we set him free
we set him free and look at that dude he
opens it up
we get the star let's go dude
let's go oh i just made it that time i
just made it
[Music]
oh that's that's telling you that's
where you got to go to beat cooper the
quick
but you know what i'm not worried about
koopa the quick right now what i'm
worried about
is just a star
sitting up here okay okay i'll take that
all right not only am i gonna win it
this time i'm gonna get that blue coin
told you
i remember there's a way to get it you
can hit a shortcut right there where you
[Music]
fall
no no there we go slow it down slow it
down i'm not i'm not even worried about
speed right now
we're gonna have to worry about speed
later though but now is not that time
chat
now is not the time to worry about speed
yo we did it let's let's go ahead
come
[Music]
oh we're not on throw him off
are you kidding me chat how could you
all suggest such a thing
this poor little penguin this mother who
just just wants her child back
bridge with the snowman is gonna be
right over
right over here there he is all right we
gotta get outsmart him
in this part right here obviously an
iconic moment in the game
oh i didn't mean to do that get up
i think we need to be on this floor
though
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no
look look look here you go you found my
precious baby
where have you been how can i ever thank
you mario
don't fall off guys don't fall off
[Music]
just don't do that either i blame the
camera
okay there we go okay i got it to zoom
out
i didn't start zoomed out i have no idea
because that's the one i had it on
[Music]
oh yeah make sure you zoom out
when it stays close you got no chance
no crushed again i'm just a stepping
stone after all
i won't gravel or grovel
here you win take this with you
this was such a great effect man
i will never forget this feeling of
running down this hall and
seeing that morph right there i will oh
it's just so good man it's such a subtle
thing too
you stepped right into my trap just as i
knew you would i warn you
friend watch your step
no no what are you doing
it's like he just i'm going to push
against this
crystal right here
oh that was a camera death right there
man
what i pushed b to jump come on dude
jump oh my gosh
scared me again scare me again calm down
calm down settle mario
settle
what was that
[Music]
all right man let's go holy crap here we
go fall guys again
mario 64 the inspiration for fall guys
look at this dude look at this
oh man i'm scared dude i'm scared
i messed up i messed up
[Music]
yeah i'm living on the edge chat i told
you i told you we're losing
now if i if i just drop off
[Music]
no
what i was trying to do is like crawl
across all right we gotta get that red
coin guys
[Music]
why does he have that like momentum
why does he have that little momentum to
it why can't he just like
man
i rushed it i rushed it i'm getting
impatient and i just i just
i flat out rushed it
[Music]
mario
oh no
yes we're there we're there we're there
we're there baby
let's go dude i loved
i loved how massive he was man
like he just felt so huge when you got
to him for the first time
you'll never be able to swing me around
a wimp like you won't throw me out of
here
never
and now like looking back he's really
not that much bigger
he's really not that much bigger
[Music]
then we gotta twirl around and around
guys
i can't i can't remember how what do i
push to oh wait i gotta push the button
to throw
i was trying to push the jump button and
didn't work like wait a second
[Music]
gur i was a bit careless this is not as
i had planned but i still hold the power
of the stars
and i still have peach
you'll get no more stars from me i'm not
finished with you yet but i'll let you
go for now you'll pay for this
later
and somehow he has this magical
teleportability where he still gives you
a key
i forgot you only had to do it once that
time
all right guys it's been fun i hope you
all have a
great tuesday and i'll see you again for
the wednesday night stream should be a
normal schedule this week so
talk to you again soon later guys